i don't know this was written in 1976
obviously this is a a topic that might
be addressed differently today but what
i did want to do what i did look up is i
said okay what is it what is a feminine
characteristic and what is a masculine
characteristic characteristic generally
speaking yeah
now
okay i'm just going to read them first
masculine this is coming from some
website about psychology right
masculine strong controlled focused
powerful centered purpose driven loves
the challenge in competition single task
oriented problem solver wants freedom
and release
makes big things small
forgets needs admiration and
appreciation wants to be needed and
respected
they're the the masculine intimacy
killer is being criticized controlled or
shut out so those are the masculine
uh
characteristics here's the feminine
characteristics free flowing open
radiant radiant
wild destructive emotion driven
seeks and gives love nurturer
multi-tasker diffused awareness
wants to gather talk vent
makes small things big
remembers
needs reassurance and attention
wants trust connection and praise
the intimacy killer is feeling unseen
unsafe or misunderstood now
um
clearly
these things every human has both these
things in a spectrum and
you could call you didn't you be i think
what makes them challenging to talk
about in this day and age is they put
man and woman on them what they should
have done is said you know
uh just black and white right two
yang yeah yeah oh ying and yang would
have been perfect right so you got the
yin personality you got the yang
personality here's how they are not
necessarily men and women because let's
face it we know a lot of women that are
strong controlled and focused we know a
lot of men that are free flowing open
radiate right so these
but i think they're generally speaking
psychologically here's some
characteristics so that's where we're at
dave are you concerned yet
is this the freaking podcast that gets
us banned finally i don't know
no i'm concerned at the depth that this
guy is going into to explain what i
think is going to be a series of
behaviors that we're going to discuss
that are really deep
yes
it's it's interesting because what he's
saying is and what he says is that
the military can shut out these
feminine characteristics and that's not
good good yeah that's what he's about to
say yeah
that one of the negative characteristics
of a militaristic organization is it
doesn't have enough of the feminine
characteristics for instance
free and open mind right those are bad
if you don't have those those you're in
a bad bad situation
so
he goes on to say uh
evidence of this aversion is of
necessity
circumstantial it embraces such
phenomena so here's some things that
kind of show
maybe this this anti-effeminate
role that you have in the military one
the importance attached to such outward
signs of sex role identification as hair
length
since the insistence on short
back and sides seems correlated with
those periods in history when sexual
differentiation was linked to hair
length we can dismiss excuses of
neatness and hygiene as rationalizations
field marshal lord woolsey stated the
true case when he said
it is very difficult to make an
englishman at any time look like a
soldier he is fond of his longish hair
hair is the glory of a woman but the
shame of a man
uh
so what he's saying is listen it's not
about hygiene it's not about convenience
which by the way i totally disagree with
this i think having short hair is
totally uh convenient
low maintenance
hygienic
neat right that's why i have the hair
that i have
when my hair gets longer than
three quarters of an inch which it
hasn't been for a long time i i can't
stand it
i don't think dang i kind of look wait
i'm looking like a like a woman i need
to shave my head right now not even in
the ballpark so dude i think he's
stretching here
i think he's doing a stretch in fact the
other thing is
how do you make how do you bring
uniformity to a person's hair
you cut it off otherwise you know you
have some dude with long red hair you
got some other dude with curly hair you
got another dude with the with uh
no hair you know you got all these
different hairstyles and all of a sudden
we look different we're not trying to
look different and you know how like
when people girls hang guys by the way
they have like longer hair and it starts
to go in front of their face and they
like whip it back right with their head
that's a that's a functionality thing i
get it but it looks pretty feminine okay
i'm saying
what about when you see a fighter
a professional fighter in the ultimate
fighting championship and he has to
adjust his hair while he's fighting by
the way same gig right same gig it
doesn't make them any less of a fighter
yeah i guess technically right you got
to do one more step for efficiency or
whatever i guess but
you know isn't that a sexual thing when
girls do that like flip their hair
that's like a that's like a mating thing
right
i was just thinking of clay guida
watching that dude fight and just like
bro how do you see and he's constantly
messing with his hair and it didn't seem
to affect him all that much that's true
and his hair was so freaking wild it was
almost like a target disrupter yeah like
his hair would be moving around same
thing with big ass beards like how does
that not throw off your punch to
someone's chin when they've got a beard
a big beard that's a problem
i don't know if this is true
but i distinctly remember being told and
i i i don't even know who told me but
your hair the one of the reasons they
talked about your hair being short is
they don't want somebody to be able to
use your hair as a as a way to
manipulate your head during hand-to-hand
combat you don't want to grab your head
and you know so i don't remember that
being like in a regulation as the
explanation but being told hey if the
guy can grab your hair and pull your
head because your hair's too long
you're wrong that's to put you at a
disadvantage you can't do that
so 100 yeah my i've always my rule was
just my role of me but i i will say i
kind of talked to my son about this
however maybe i'm wrong didn't didn't
really tell my daughters this i said hey
if your hair is long enough for someone
to grab
then that's a problem you don't want to
have hair that's long enough for someone
to grab i told that to my son i didn't i
might have told to my daughters but i
didn't enforce it
it didn't of course right so i guess i'm
whatever uh
uh what is that sexist yeah
no you're not sexist but you know
yeah what is it when you treat someone
different right you discriminate a
little bit
yeah well whatever although i've told
all i told all my daughters like hey
i can take care of this problem we can
shave that head i always offer my
daughter's haircuts
they've never said yes yeah i say i say
it as a joke
like i don't know if i'd want to shave
my daughter's head but i told my son the
same thing i was like yeah you do want
it short yeah so when you get in a fight
or whatever they can't grab your head or
your hair like that oh that's what it is
double standard double standard double
standard that's true the doubles
although i didn't i gave them the option
yeah but you didn't enforce it though
wait did you enforce it with your son
though no but i mean it kind of makes
sense hey man hey so as far as your role
and your level of enforcement it was the
same oh hey how they behave that's
different they got different lies i get
it you know but hey man no just i kind
of thought i might get my middle when my
middle daughter was wrestling
yeah you know and going into some
freaking savagery yeah they don't have a
favorite wrestling no yeah or they do no
they don't but still let's face it
that's the principle let's face it you
roll it you're you're a female wrestler
and you're rolling with the it's
kind of like thug rose right yeah yeah
are we not looking at thug rose thinking
hell yeah
we are we are looking at the girls
even her opponent
yeah she shared her last one yeah yeah
she never had shaved the first time but
you know my daughter would get the
cornrow braids like the real tight
braids right that's kind of a war
mode you can't grab those by the way
yeah i mean in the back yeah well if you
have some kind of a ponytail sticking
out the back but yeah for some reason my
daughter didn't really have that they
were just tight
interesting well done well isn't it the
same for beard though like a big beard
totally like i see a big beard and i'm
like bruh yeah like
it's the exact same thing yeah i look at
someone with a big beard i think just
handle it you must be super super double
extra confident you think that someone's
not gonna
freaking get a wrist wrap on that bad
boy and slam your head in the pavement
well i feel like the beard is in a less
opportune position i guess technically
still very useful very useful but you
know on the top of the head that's like
i'd say there's like a good level or two
more control yeah it's very shocking
when i see guys with long hair
again you must have a lot of confidence
that someone's not going to grab you and
that's one of my favorite takedowns on
the battlefield just grab a handful of
hair and slam people down it works good
bro watch the
girl fights on youtube well if you have
the time bro that's that's gonna be the
default at some point they're just gonna
grab hair and it's like they kind of
nullify both attacks when they're both
grabbing hair so it's man it's like
proof you know in the field yeah field
proven combat scenario
drunk chicks scrapping it out on youtube
it's totally true it's totally true